le cours est terminée faut que j'y aille
on se parle demain je vais nulle part
t'inquiète je m'appelle gardner elliott
je suis né sur mars mais j'ai enfin
trouvé une bonne raison d'aller sur
terre
je pourrais la voir en vrai coeur ne
supportera pas la gravité terrestre
c'est trop risqué
ça vaut le coup c'est quand on veut se
rapprocher de quelqu'un qu'on se rend
compte à quel point on est loin
salut tulsa
où est ce qu'on va tu voulais voir le
monde qu'est ce que vous préférez sur
terre leur rêve
est super rebelle
que ce passe
il a plus beaucoup de temps
il faut que tu repartent
[Musique]
tulsa qu'est ce que tu préfères sur
terre
c'est toi car tu meurs
[Musique]